kyte ist ihr großes thema ihre vorlesung
über gerechtigkeit erreichen
mittlerweile ein millionenpublikum dank
internet fernsehen radio
was denken sie ist die welt insgesamt
eher gerechter geworden in den letzten
zehn jahren
das finde ich nicht in einigen teilen
der welt hat sich der lebensstandard
verbessert und menschen von der armut
befreit
das ist aus wirtschaftlicher und
moralischer sicht gut aber während viele
länder ein wirtschaftswachstum
verzeichnen sind die ungleichheit und
die kluft zwischen reich und arm in fast
allen ländern auf der welt massiv
grösser geworden und daraus erwachsen
schwierige gerechtigkeitsfrage
ja ich denke die zunehmende ungleichheit
fordert die politik viel direkter und
unmittelbarer heraus als in früheren
jahrzehnten
sie muss sich der frage stellen was eine
gerechte gesellschaft ausmacht die
wachsende ungleichheit ist also eine
gelegenheit und notwendigkeit für
philosophische diskussionen in der
öffentlichkeit affäre mann hatte über
steuerhinterziehung gesprochen über
steuerflucht was ist nicht daran genau
ungerecht
sie ist auf zwei ebenen ungerecht zuerst
einmal aus der sicht der demokratischen
verantwortlichkeit habe demokratische
staaten haben sich entschieden steuern
zu erheben um das gemeinwohl zu fördern
und auch die ungleichheit zu verringern
wenn also gewisse bürger die gemäss
demokratische übereinkunft ihren beitrag
an steuern zahlen müssten sich dieser
pflicht entziehen indem sie in
steuerparadiese in übersee ausweichen
dann nehmen sie ihre bürgerpflicht nicht
das ist einerseits eine ungerechtigkeit
weil dem staat steuereinnahmen entgehen
aber es ist auch eine verletzung des
bürgerrechts denn die einflussreichsten
und erfolgreichsten mitglieder der
gesellschaft finden möglichkeiten so
zusagen ihre bürgerpflicht zu outsourcen
sich ihr zu entziehen
damit verletzten sie ihre bürgerpflicht
und verletzten das prinzip der
gerechtigkeit
wir hängen gerechtigkeit und demokratie
zusammen
aber sie haben dazu ja auch viel darüber
nachgedacht und sie sagen auch es gibt
gerechtigkeit probleme die wirklich die
demokratie gefährden
ja es gibt zwei gründe weshalb die
wachsende kluft zwischen reich und arm
und sorgen machen sollte
beim ersten geht es um gerechtigkeit
beim zweiten mehr um demokratie aus
gründen der gerechtigkeit ist es unfair
wenn menschen die sich einsetzen und
hart arbeiten erleben dass arbeit so
unterschiedlich entlohnt
einige verdienen sehr viel und sind
wohlhabend während andere sehr wenig
besitzen
das wirft fragen der fairness auf
philosophen haben verschiedene theorien
der verteilungsgerechtigkeit entwickelt
und sich damit auseinandergesetzt wie
viel und welche ungleichheit vereinbar
ist mit einer gerechten gesellschaft
darin liegt der eine grund warum
ungleichheit ein problem ist aber es
gibt noch einen anderen grund
wenn wohlhabende und wenig bemittelte
immer unterschiedlichere leben führen
was wir in vielen demokratischen
gesellschaften beobachten können dann
wird der gemeinsinn unterwandert das
bewusstsein eines gemeinsamen ziels
einer gemeinsam gelebten erfahrung was
in der demokratie unabdingbar ist
das ist der zweite grund sich wegen der
ungleichheit sorgen zu machen
der erste grund ist uns vertraut
wir kennen die diskussion über
verteilungsgerechtigkeit aber oft
übersehen wir wie sich die ungleichheit
auf den sozialen zusammenhalt und den
gemeinsinn auswirkt der nötig ist damit
sich die bürger in ein gemeinsames
projekt eingebunden fühlen
sharing income and project wenn die
ungleichheit betrifft also die
gerechtigkeit und die demokratie lassen
sie nicht auf den zweiten punkt etwas
später zurückkommen bleiben wir zuerst
mal noch ein bisschen bei der
ungleichheit in der schweiz gab es große
debatten darüber dass die sogenannte
abzocker initiative angenommen wurde
das wurde in ganz europa breit
diskutiert das war eine initiative die
eigentlich primär die aktionärsrechte
stärken wollte aber viele leute haben
sie angenommen weil sie primär daran
interessiert sind die hohen saläre die
boni einzuebnen
sie sagen das sind zu höhere löhne die
da bezahlt werden als ein problem der
ungleichheit in der lohn verteilung ist
das für sie ein thema über das sie sich
persönlich aufregend diese
managergehälter da gibt es mehrere
aspekte auf der ebene der
moralphilosophie und der
verteilungsgerechtigkeit ist es wichtig
zu fragen ob es gerecht ist dass
hedgefonds manager und lehrer so
ungleich entlöhnt werden aus sicht der
laissez faire politik des freien marktes
und der bürgerlich-liberalen
gerechtigkeit theorie lautet die antwort
wie folgt wenn diese unterschiede das
resultat des freien und freiwilligen
austausch sind und wenn die dienste
fähigkeiten und talente gewisser leute
auf dem markt mehr wert sind als die von
anderen dann sind diese ungleichheiten
gerecht vorausgesetzte austausch ist
freiwillig gemäß liberaler theorien wäre
es eine verletzung der freiheit diese
ungleichheit durch steuern zu
nivellieren
doch für mich ist das ein schwaches
argument denn dass in einer
marktwirtschaft gewisse leute mit ihren
talenten ungeheuren wohlstand anläufen
ist großenteils nicht ihr verdienst
sondern das resultat glücklicher
umstände
da sieht man sehr gut beim
spitzenfußballer der eine unmenge geld
verdient ist es sein verdienst weil er
ein so guter sportler ist natürlich gibt
er sein bestes und trainiert hart aber
ist es wirklich sein verdienst
wenn nicht dann kann man nichts sagen er
habe das moralische recht das vermögen
das er damit verdient für sich zu
behalten
ein weiterer moralischer zu fall kommt
hinzu
in unserem land sind fußball-stars
berühmt wir schauen uns gern fußball
spiele an
aber auch das ist nicht der verdienst
des fußball stars sondern sein glück aus
diesen beiden gründen kann man nicht
sagen dass vielverdiener ob hedgefonds
manager oder sport stars das recht haben
dieses geld für sich zu behalten nicht
leute bereit sind sehr viel zu bezahlen
dann werden die leute gar nichts mehr
machen aus ihren talenten dann haben wir
gar keine guten fußballer oder keine
operativen mehr oder keine großartigen
künstler mehr lohnt sich ja gar nicht
sein talent zu vervollkommnen
das argument des finanziellen anreizes
ist bis zu einem gewissen punkt legitim
anreize sind nötig um die talente und
fähigkeiten zu fördern welche die
gesellschaft will und braucht aber eines
darf man nicht vergessen
finanzielle anreize wurden geschaffen um
menschen dazu zu bringen ihre talente
für das gemeinwohl einzusetzen
das ist die philosophische basis der
attraktivität von anreizen
wenn also der dienst am gemeinwohl
gehaltsunterschiede rechtfertigt dann
lohnt sich folgende frage trägt ein
hedgefonds-manager der tausendmal mehr
verdient als sagen wir mal eine
kindergärtnerin tausendmal mehr bei zum
gemeinwohl als
die kindergärten ich denke damit
gelangen sie ins zentrum der frage nach
der gerechtigkeit von löhnen
wenn wir das nicht beweisen können dann
können wir nicht fordern dass der
hedgefonds manager seinen ganzen
verdienst behalten darf vielleicht
wollen wir das finanzsystem in gang
halten und finden dafür sei das bezahlen
hohe prämien nötig aber man darf nicht
vergessen dass der anreiz ursprünglich
als instrument gedacht war
um den beitrag zum gemeinwohl zu fördern
der markt darf was der wert des marktes
sein könnte in ihrem neuesten buch was
man für geld nicht kaufen kann
haben sie ein bedenken sie sagen der
markt beginnt überschuss zu fassen er
umfasst zu viele unserer lebensbereiche
und deswegen sind die eigentlich nicht
mehr nur in einer marktwirtschaft
sondern wir werden zu einer
marktgesellschaft und das finden sie
problematisch jetzt können sie dies
jetzt ja klose ein paar beispielen fest
machen wo sehen sie denn diese
ausdehnung des marktes
lassen sie mich zuerst erklären was ich
mit dieser verschiebung hin zu
marktgesellschaft meine in den letzten
drei jahrzehnten sind wir fast ohne es
zu merken
von einer marktwirtschaft zu einer
marktgesellschaft geworden
der unterschied ist folgender die
marktwirtschaft ist ein nützliches
werkzeug für die organisation produktive
tätigkeiten aber eine marktgesellschaft
ist eine lebensweise in der alles zum
verkauf steht in der das
marktwirtschaftliche denken jeden aspekt
des lebens zu beherrschen beginnt es
betrifft nicht nur materielle güter
sondern erfasst auch das familienleben
persönliche beziehungen gesundheit
bildung nationale sicherheit das
öffentliche leben und das finde ich
besorgniserregend mein buch ist kein
plädoyer gegen märkte oder gegen
kapitalismus
es ist vielmehr ein plädoyer
dafür märkte und marktwirtschaftliches
denken am richtigen ort einzusetzen
messing was in unserer politik in den
letzten jahrzehnten nicht diskutiert
wurde ist die frage wo die märkte dem
gemeinwohl dienen und wo sie nicht
hingehören wo sie unverkäufliche werte
unterwandert was meinen sie eigentlich
mit marktlogik oder markt denken lassen
sie mich ein paar beispiele nennen um
das zu veranschaulichen
der organhandel die meisten länder
verbieten den verkauf von ihren auf dem
freien markt doch weil wir mehr organe
brauchen für menschen die darauf
angewiesen sind sagen viele ökonomen das
angebot an organen würde steigen wenn
man den freien markt spielen diese
morgens trotzdem lassen dass die meisten
länder nicht zu aus mehreren gründen
zuerst einmal aus angst dass dann sehr
arme leute zwangsläufig ihre organe an
wohlhabende verkaufen würden
und es ist fraglich ob ein armer
indischer bauer der findet nur so könne
er sein kind zur schule schicken so
etwas freiwillig tut da gilt es zwang
und ungleichheit zu vermeiden
es gibt einen zweiten möglichen einwand
wollen wir leute dazu ermutigen ihren
körper als eine sammlung von
einzelteilen zu betrachten
aus denen man profit schlagen kann denn
man muss sich fragen wie sehr der mensch
durch den organhandel abgewertet wird
diskutiert man also darüber wo märkte
sinnvoll sind muss man sich zuerst
fragen handelt es sich um einen
freiwilligen handel
oder steckt wirtschaftlicher zwang wie
verzweifelte armut dahinter und auch wo
das nicht der fall ist muss man sich
fragen wird dadurch ein wichtiges
menschliches oder öffentliches gut
entwertet oder korrumpiert beispiel
sollten
wissen sie dass im irak und in
afghanistan mehr angestellte von
privaten sicherheitsfirmen im einsatz
waren als us-soldaten und das ohne
öffentliche debatte darüber ob wir den
krieg an private organisationen
outsourcen
doch seltener armeen gelten seit jeher
als fragwürdig unter anderem wegen eines
einwand den russo vehement vertrat das
outsourcen des militärdienstes ist wie
das outsourcen einer bürgerpflicht
die sorge ist also dass im bereich der
nationalen sicherheit mit dem einsatz
von söldnern die bürgerpflicht und die
demokratische verantwortung unterwandert
werden
sag ich mal normalbürger relativ
speziell die frage der out geschossen
streitkräften sehr sehr großes problem
die frage mit den organen da könnte man
sagen ja da gibt es natürlich noch ein
anderes argument dagegen die leute
sollen die organe auch nicht verkaufen
weil sie sich selber möglicherweise je
nach organ natürlich auch schädigen also
wenn man eine niere hergibt dann hat man
nur noch ein mann läuft er gefahr wenn
man erkrankt dann selber vielleicht
möglicherweise an etwas zu sterben
deswegen könnte es gefährlich sein die
eigenen organe zu verkaufen leben zu
verkaufen
aber nehmen wir mal noch ein beispiel
was vielleicht noch stärker am alltag
der leute sein könnte sie beschreiben in
ihrem buch ja ganz viele wunderbare
beispiele eines davon hat mich besonders
beschäftigt nämlich das public theater
in new york es gibt immer aufführungen
im sommer von shakespeare im central
park die sagen die wollen gerne
shakespeare den leuten näher bringen die
tickets sind gratis
weil so viele leute diese tickets haben
wollen für diese schecks bei
aufführungen gibt es immer schlangen die
sich bilden vor den schaltern
schon stunden bevor diese schalter
aufgehen und artikels kriegen kann
dann gab es einige leute wie sie das
beschrieben haben die sagten ich habe
keine zeit mich in die schlange zu
stellen
alle einen an der für mich sich in die
schlange stellen und für mich dann das
gratisticket holt um diese schlangen
stehe haben ein salär gekriegt bis zu
125 dollar was ist daran verkehrt
eigentlich könnte man sagen naja ist der
markt ist eigentlich doch ganz klar war
dann brauche ich mich damit hinzustellen
wie sie richtig sagen zeigt sich da der
markt in voller aktion
dabei bezeichnen die veranstalter das
freie shakespeare theater als
volkstheater
damit wollen sie shakespeare zu den
leuten bringen
im central park im sommer als ein
ausdruck von gemeinschaft als eine art
volksfest wenn ich sie also an höhere
damit sie sich in die schlange stellen
um ein ticket für mich zu ergattern
finden sie vielleicht dass das ihre zeit
wert ist
sagen wir mal sie brauchen das geld und
mir dient es weil ich zu sehr
beschäftigt bin
also höre ich sie an ich will nicht
schlange stehen
aber ich will das theaterstück sehen uns
beiden mag das team aber der
gemeinschaft als ganzes und den
veranstaltern des freien shakespeare
theaters ist damit weniger gedient denn
da man leute anheuern kann die für
tickets schlange stehen besteht das
publikum aus typen wie mir der es sich
leisten kann jemanden dafür zu bezahlen
dass er ihm ein ticket besorgt
vielleicht sogar einen obdachlosen
das verändert den gesellschaftlichen den
öffentlichen charakter dieses
sommertheaters im park lassen sie mich
ein ähnliches beispiel in washington dc
kann man firmen buchen
die sich auf schlange stehen
spezialisiert haben und das für einen
übernehmen
wenn ich einen platz in einer
kongressanhörung haben möchte oder die
beweisführung des höchsten gerichtshofs
in einem wichtigen
hören will muss ich dafür anstehen nach
dem prinzip first come first serve sieht
denn die platzzahl ist beschränkt
aber wenn ich keine zeit habe schlange
zu stehen kann ich zu einer
spezialisierten firma gehen die hat
jemanden an der das geld braucht und
schlange steht vielleicht sogar über
nacht oder im regen und kurz vor beginn
der anhörung komme ich oder vielmehr
kommt der lobbyist der die firma gebucht
hat und setzt sich auf seinen platz in
der ersten reihe
das ist kurt mann verkauft den zutritt
zum kongress anhörung oder zum obersten
gericht oder lässt zu dass firmen den
zutritt verkaufen was auch korrupt ist
beispiel leicht anders gelagert weil es
natürlich um demokratische prozesse geht
es geht darum dass man teilnehmen kann
debatten ja auch wichtig sind für die
demokratie
währenddessen das shakespeare stück zu
hören hat mit demokratie als erstmal
nicht so viel zu tun sind die beispiele
nicht unterschiedlichen schweregraden
ich würde sagen sie sind anders aber nur
geringfügig ich habe das beispiel der
firmen genannt die professionelles
schlange stehen für kongressanhörungen
anbieten weil es anschaulich und
dramatisch zeigt wie das vermarkten
einer handlung auch wenn es auf
gegenseitigem einverständnis von käufer
und verkäufer beruht demokratische werte
korrumpiert den regierungsvertreter
werden gewissermaßen verkauft warum
besteht für mich nur ein kleiner
unterschied zwischen den beiden beispiel
das freie theater im park wird nicht von
einer regierungsinstitutionen
organisiert aber es ist eine öffentliche
veranstaltung die dem gemeinwohl dienst
löschen
denn unter anderem will sie menschen aus
verschiedenen schichten für eine
gemeinsame öffentliche erfahrung
zusammen bringen
das theater ist von privaten
veranstaltern orga
visiert nicht von einer regierungs
institution aber wenn alle öffentlichen
veranstaltungen auf öffentlichen plätzen
von märkten und geld beherrscht werden
schade dass einer demokratischen
gesellschaft es schadet dem gemein sind
und dem bewusstsein dass wir alle im
gleichen boot sitzen
deshalb zeigen diese beispiele ähnlich
korrumpieren de praktiker es gibt ein
skigebiet in der schweiz vcs und in laax
kann man seit letztem jahr eine vip
karte kaufen
damit muss man nicht schlange stehen das
heißt man kann sozusagen an der
warteschlange beim skilift vorbei direkt
sich hinstellen und es gab keine debatte
ist das eigentlich in ordnung und
interessanterweise waren die leute ein
bisschen geteilt ungefähr die hälfte
fand das stoßen und fand es gehört dazu
dass man sich in die schlange stellt
ungefähr die andere hälfte fand das
nicht so schlimm und sagte na ja wenn
die das geld wenn das den wert ist das
zu bezahlen dann ist das auch in ordnung
meine frage an sie glauben sie dass so
viele es nicht so schlimm fanden lag
daran dass ich jeweils pro tag nur zehn
solche vip tickets gibt oder lag es
vielleicht daran dass das vip ticket nur
30 franken teuer ist das der normale
skipass dieses beispiel mit dem zugang
zu ski pisten ist meiner meinung nach
ein etwas anderer fall wobei skifahren
in der schweiz vielleicht so etwas wie
eine zivile religion ist aber im
allgemeinen kann man den zugang zur
skipiste nicht vergleichen mit dem
zugang zu gemeinsam genutzten
öffentlichen plätzen
ich denke davon hängt es ab ob solche
anreize korrumpieren
ich gebe ihnen ein anderes sehr
verbreitet
in flughäfen gibt es schnellere check in
schalter für passagiere die mehr geld
für ihr ticket bezahlen
im sonderservice den diese fluggäste
genießen gibt es ein interessantes
detail wer ein teures ticket kauft kann
einerseits früher an bord gehen und hat
mehr platz für sein handgepäck
da verkauft die fluggesellschaft einen
service und eine annehmlichkeit aber wie
steht es mit dem recht schneller durch
die sicherheitskontrolle zu gehen dass
man als inhaber eines teuren tickets
auch genießt das ist etwas anderes
früher an bord gehen zu können kann man
als eine art wirtschaftsgut bezeichnen
das nichts mit dem leben einer
gesellschaft zu tun dass man aber durch
die sicherheitskontrolle gehen muss
dient der nationalen sicherheit und dem
verhindern von attentaten
hier ist das gemeinwohl mehr betroffen
als beim früheren besteigt des flugzeugs
es geht also darum wo man die grenze
sitzt
ich möchte hier zwei dinge an merken wo
wir die grenze setzen hängt vom
charakter der aktivität ab und wie stark
sie zu den eigenheiten des gemeinwesens
und unserer zivilgesellschaft beiträgt
die pisten sind auf der einen seite
dieser grenze und schlange stehen für
kongressanhörungen oder verhandlungen im
obersten gericht auf der anderen die
sicherheitskontrolle ist in einer
kategorie und das besteigen des
flugzeugs in einer anderen
solche fragen müssen wir stellen aber
was mich verwundert und mich unter
anderem dazu bewogen hat das buch zu
schreiben
wie verbreitet diese tendenz ist sie ist
relativ neu ob auf skipisten im
flughafen oder bei veranstaltungen wie
shakespeare im park oder bei
kongressanhörungen keine dieser
marktmechanismen existierte vor 30
jahren sie sind in den letzten drei
jahrzehnten entstanden und
veranschaulichen wie markt werte und
markt praktiken in jedem lebensbereich
eine wachsende rolle spielen
was in der heutigen politik meiner
meinung nach fehlt ist die diskussion
der frage nach den moralischen grenzen
des marktes die frage wo die märkte
hingehören und wo nicht
wo sie werte verdrängen zerstören oder
untergraben moralische oder
gesellschaftliche werte denen wir sorge
tragen sollten
moral und markt sind zwei getrennte
sphären oder zumindest sind sie auf gar
kein vergleich zu setzen wie
widersprechen sich die beiden oder wie
gehören sie zusammen es gab ja immer
auch der retter gedachten der markt ist
moralisch ich finde es ist ein fehler
davon auszugehen dass
marktwirtschaftliche überlegungen und
methoden oder fehlentwicklungen des
freien marktes die gerechtigkeit oder
das gemeinwohl definieren können ich
denke eines der probleme unserer politik
der letzten 30 jahre ist dass wir eine
markt verherrlichenden glauben verfallen
sind
dieser setzt voraus dass die märkte die
wichtigsten instrumente für die
erlangung des gemeinwohls sind und dass
sie definieren können was gerecht ist
ich finde das ist ein fehler ich bin
überzeugt dass es zwischen markt und
moral eine wichtige beziehung gibt und
geben muss und zwar folgende märkte sind
werkzeuge
sie definieren weder was gerechtigkeit
ist noch definieren sie das gemeinwohl
sie mögen nützlich sein zur organisation
produktive tätigkeiten und zur
verteilung von gütern und man kann
diskutieren welchen demokratischen
zielen sie dienen aber märkte sind nicht
mehr als werkzeug was die beziehung
zwischen moral und magd anbelangt
sollten wir den einsatz von märkten
durch moralische argumente und
rechtliche überlegungen steuern
diese sollten uns verstehen lassen wo
märkte sinnvoll sind zum beispiel für
die produktion und die verteilung von
materiellen gütern wie flachbild
fernsehern autos und so weiter und wo
märkte werte korrumpieren könnten zum
beispiel im öffentlichen leben in der
familie der gesundheit der erziehung
oder der nationalen sicherheit
nur wenn wir überlegungen über werte und
gerechtigkeit an stellen finden wir
heraus wo märkte sinnvoll sind und dem
gemeinwohl dienen
das sollten wir uns überlegen das
führten sie eigentlich zurück auch zu
ihrer zu ihren anderen büchern über
gerechtigkeit sind ja schon sehr sehr
lange im thema gerechtigkeit drin werden
zu den sogenannten kommunitarismus
gezählt ob sie das mögen oder nicht
also sind ein eher kritisch eingestellt
beispielsweise haben sie kritisch
auseinandergesetzt mit der gerechtigkeit
theorie von john rawls schon sehr früh
was liegt ihnen am herzen oder wie
definieren wir denn dieses gemeinwohl
diese idee dessen was uns allen wichtig
ist vielleicht auch heilig ist was uns
zusammenhält das gesellschaft wie kann
die das bestimmen dass sie mich mit dem
beginnen was sie eben erwähnt haben die
beziehungen zwischen dem gemeinwohl und
den gerechtigkeit theorie ich glaube es
gibt eine tendenz zur folgenden annahme
die unter anderem auch die philosophie
betrifft
sie haben das werk von john rawls
erwähnt und auch jürgen habermas teilt
diese sicht
es ist eine idee die auf kant zurückgeht
da wir uns nicht einig sind was ein
gutes leben ausmacht da wir uns nicht
darüber einig sind was bürgerliche
tugenden sind und wie wir güter bewerten
sollen müssen wir versuchen grundlegende
fragen über gerechtigkeit und recht zu
entscheiden ohne uns von unseren
gegensätzlichen konzepten bezüglich des
guten lebens oder der bürgerlichen
tugenden beeinflussen zu lassen
das ist eine sehr starke idee
qualität auch ja die idee dass regierung
und gesetz neutral sein sollten und die
moralischen und spirituellen
uneinigkeiten der bürger in
pluralistischen gesellschaften
respektiert werden müssen
das ist eine starke und auch
verständliche idee denn in unseren
modernen pluralistischen gesellschaften
wollen wir uneinigkeiten vermeiden die
sich in diskussionen über das gute
zeigen und wir wollen nicht riskieren
dass anderen menschen werte aufgezwungen
werden die sie nicht teilen
doch es ist ein fehler anzunehmen man
könne gerechtigkeit angesichts unserer
gegensätzlichen konzepte des guten
lebens neutral definieren aus zwei
gründen vorzulesen
erstens viele fragen der gerechtigkeit
und der rechte können wir nicht
entscheiden ohne dass wir die
dahinterliegende moralische kontroverse
in betracht oft kann man fragen der
gerechtigkeit nicht abgrenzen von fragen
hinsichtlich des guten lebens der
bürgerlichen tugenden oder der bewertung
von gütern
aber auch dort wo wir es tun können ist
es falsch moralische und spirituelle
fragen aus öffentlichen diskussionen
auszuklammern
der versuch bürger dazu zu bewegen in
öffentlichen belangen ihrer moralischen
oder spirituellen überzeugungen
auszuklammern führt zu einer leeren
politik zu einer öffentlichen diskussion
ohne tiefere bedeutung und ziel
ich finde genau das ist in unserem
öffentlichen leben in den letzten drei
jahrzehnten passiert und das ist einer
der gründe warum in fast allen
demokratischen gesellschaften
verbreitete frustration über den
politischen diskurs herrscht
die leute finden in der politik gehe es
um technokratie und führungsprobleme
nicht um große fragen nicht um werte und
niemand findet technokratische
öffentliche debatten inspirierend
deshalb sind die leute so frustriert
über die demokratie und die diskussionen
in der öffentlichkeit aus diesen beiden
gründen der eine ist philosophisch unter
anderem politisch brauchen wir einen
öffentlichen dialog der die moral
stärker gewichtet in pluralistischen
gesellschaften sollten wir bürger
ermuntern bei öffentlichen diskussionen
ihre moralischen und sogar ihre
spirituellen überzeugungen einzubringen
und miteinander zu diskutieren und ich
denke wir müssen zwingend miteinander
über die bedeutung des gemeinwohls reden
wir können die gerechtigkeit nicht von
fragen des gemeinwohls trennen
so argumentiere ich in meinem buch dann
frage ich mich natürlich sofort ich
komme aus einem land der schweiz in dem
die direkte demokratie haben
man sieht aber immer wieder die
stimmbeteiligung beispielsweise ist
nicht zu hoch und es wird oft beklagt
dass ich zu wenig leute auch wirklich
einmischen obwohl sie die rechte dazu
hätte wie stellen sie sich das denn vor
wie sollen denn die leute eingebunden
werden in so einen öffentlichen dialog
darüber was uns eigentlich verbindet was
dieses public gut sein soll
idealerweise sollte dieser öffentliche
dialog von den politischen parteien und
den politikern unterstützt werden
diese werden sich wohl als letzte ändern
politischer parteien haben ihren anteil
an der heutigen art des öffentlichen
dialogs
wenn möglich vermeiden sie
auseinandersetzungen vor allem wenn es
um werte geht deshalb denke ich wenn dir
das öffentliche leben und den
demokratischen dialog erneuern wollen
müssen wir orte gelegenheiten und
diskussions formen finden um miteinander
über ethische fragen reden zu können
über werte im öffentlichen leben über
gerechte
zeit in der zivilgesellschaft und in
sozialen bewegungen sowie in den medien
und in der höheren bildung
wir müssen junge leute dazu befähigen
erfolgreiche bürger zu sein die große
auch ethische fragen r8 von können die
zivilgesellschaft soziale bewegungen
medien höhere bildung an diesen orten
kann staatsbürgerliche bildung erfolgen
ich denke eigentlich geht es um die
frage wie wir die staatsbürgerliche
bildung wieder aktivieren können das
können wir unter anderem erreichen indem
wir auf allen diesen ebenen einen
öffentlichen dialog fördern der die
moral stärker gewichtet dadurch haben
wir vielleicht einen gewissen einfluss
auf die nationale politik welche die
parteien anbieten
bild natürlich immer auch naja wenn man
in einer demokratie lebt und einander
zuhört und gemeinsam bestimmen was ist
das gute nachdem wir streben dann geht
es auch so sein dass der konsens enorm
wichtig wird aber ein stück weit auch
einfach diejenigen sagen wir mal die die
stärksten meinungsmacher sind gewinnen
werden aber aus philosoph müssen sie
doch eigentlich sagen es gibt gewisse
dinge die sollten uns heilig sein
die dürfen dann nicht nur weil die
öffentliche meinung dass sagt verkauft
werden oder aufs spiel gesetzt werden
oder übertrumpft werden weil sie ebenso
wichtig sind also meine frage ist gerade
in einer pluralistischen gesellschaft
könnte es nicht sein dass dann eine
stimme überhand nimmt die ihnen gerade
diese gefahr besteht immer
aber sie lässt sich nicht vermeiden
politik demokratische politik ist eine
riskante tätigkeit
das kann man nicht bestreiten denn es
besteht immer das risiko dass die
mehrheit etwas falsches beschließt dafür
gibt es nur eine lösung
man muss sicherstellen dass bei allen
mehrheitsbeschlüssen die möglich
besteht nochmals darauf zurückzukommen
damit nichts für immer fixiert ist aber
ich würde sagen auch wenn man die
öffentliche argumentation bezüglich des
gemeinwohls neutral zu halten versucht
kann man das risiko nicht umgehen
es gibt keine risikofreie version der
politik und auch keine risikofreie
gerechtigkeits theorie die uns vor den
uneinigkeiten in einer pluralistischen
gesellschaft bewahren wird nicht nur ich
gehe dieses risiko ein indem ich sage
man sollte moralische und spirituelle
argumente in die politik einfließen
lassen denn auch unsere diskussionen
über fundamentale rechte und
gerechtigkeit sind oft kontrovers und
anfechtbar und manchmal kommt etwas
falsches dabei heraus das risiko geht
also nicht nur derjenige ein der findet
man müsse unterschiedliche konzepte des
gemeinwohls einbeziehen
dieses risiko ist in der demokratie
selbst angesiedelt und wir müssen uns
dieser gefahr bewusst sein
sie plädieren sehr stark dafür dass wir
uns darüber austauschen was gerecht ist
was unsere moralischen überzeugungen
sind und sie sind damit ja auch äußerst
erfolgreich wenn sie in brasilien
sprechen in den usa sprechen in harvard
sind ja schon seit 30 jahren dozent aber
auch in korea in china in japan überall
kommen sehr viele leute zu ihren
vorlesungen sie fühlen gerne auch mal
eine halle für 10.000 leute sind sehr
erfolgreich damit auch mit ihrer methode
mit beispielen zu arbeiten
sie arbeiten ein bisschen sagt man oft
wie sokrates sie verwickeln die
zuhörenden in beispiele und argumente
gegenargumente tasten sich vor
können sie eigentlich selber noch dazu
lernen oder sind die argumente bezüglich
gerechtigkeit mittlerweile eigentlich
erschöpft und sie finden einfach bloß
neue beispiele um aktuell zu bleiben
du lernst anfang ich lerne
wenn ich unterrichte vor allem in
philosophie vorlesung wenn man lehrt
gehört auch das lernen immer dazu
und wie sie gesagt haben versuche ich
philosophie über diskussionen zu
vermitteln die studierenden sitzen nicht
einfach da und notieren sich was sie
hören
ich lade sie viel mehr ein miteinander
und mit mir zu diskutieren und auch mit
den philosophen die sie lesen und ich
ermuntere sie nicht nur die texte
berühmter philosophen wie aristoteles
kant oder john stuart mill zu lesen
sondern auch aktuelle politische und
juristische kontroversen zu
berücksichtigen
die philosophische fragen aufwerfen das
ist meine art philosophie zu leeren
aber ich will damit nicht nur die
aufmerksamkeit der studierenden wecken
das ist nur ein aspekt
ich finde so funktioniert philosophie
vor allem die politische philosophie und
die moralphilosophie und so hat sie
immer funktioniert über den dialog über
die argumentation in dem man annahmen
hinterfragt das hat schon sokrates im
alten athen getan er verkroch sich nicht
in die einsamkeit seines zimmers
umzuschreiben
er verwickelte seine zuhörer in
diskussion
er hinterfragte ihre annahmen er begann
einen dir ich denke die philosophie
erwächst aus dieser art dialog des
hinterfragen und argumentieren so unter
richtig aber auch in meinen büchern
nenne ich beispiele um einen dialog in
gang zu setzen und um diese bücher nicht
nur den studenten sondern allen bürgern
zugänglich zu machen
stellung zu nehmen
in zeitungen blogs engagieren sich für
themen denken sie politischen
philosophen hätten da eine spezielle
verantwortung sich auch einzumischen in
politische debatten
ich würde es so sagen ich finde die
philosophie hat sich in jüngster zeit
immer mehr von der
sich kite abgekapselt vieles in der
philosophie ist hochtechnisch abstrakt
und sogar schleierhaft geworden
ich kritisiere die philosophen nicht die
abstrakte werke schreiben zu denen die
öffentlichkeit keinen zugang hat auch
sie haben ihre berechtigung
aber ich denke die philosophie hat die
wichtige aufgabe sich mit der welt und
der öffentlichkeit auseinanderzusetzen
vor allem die moralphilosophie und die
politische philosophie und zwar wegen
des dialogischen charakters der
philosophie und wegen der öffentlichen
verantwortung jener die sich auf diese
dimension der philosophie einlassen
wollen wie gesagt ich finde nicht dass
das jeder für das oft tun sollte aber
ich empfinde es als verlust wenn die
philosophie ihre fähigkeit verliert sich
mit den sorgen und den dilemmas normaler
frauen und männer auseinander zu setzen
und zwar in einer verständlichen sprache
die verbindung schafft zu ihren sorgen
dilemmas ängste und erwartungen
ich finde öffentliche philosophie ist
etwas wichtiges auch wenn sich nicht
alle philosophen dafür engagieren
die vorlesung die ich schon erwähnt habe
dich inhalten über gerechtigkeit dies
immer ausgebucht es gibt etwas mir
glaube ich aus 1000 100 sitzplätze und
die werden per los vergeben was würden
sie tun micro sunday wenn es einen
schwarzmarkt gäbe und sie zu hören für
die tickets ich war mit diesem problem
konfrontiert als ich in anderen ländern
zum beispiel in asien vorlesungen gab
dort sagte man mir im internet würden
plätze verkauft in solchen fällen frage
ich jeweils am anfang der vorlesung ob
jemand im hörsaal 1 tickets auf dem
schwarzmarkt gekauft
es gab ja nicht zugeben aber es dient
mir als beispiel als einstieg und mit
ihnen darüber zu diskutieren was man mit
geld kaufen sollte und was nicht ich
nutze es als philosophisches beispiel
und frage sie ist es falsch auf dem
schwarzmarkt ein ticket für eine
philosophie vorlesung zu kaufen bei
konzerten finden wir es in ordnung für
lady gaga kaufen die leute tickets auf
dem schwarzmarkt
wie ist das bei einer philosophie
vorlesung was ist da ähnlich und was ist
anders wenn man tickets für eine
kongressanhörung kauft oder wenn man
mehr bezahlt um schneller auf der
skipiste zu sein wenn studenten also ein
ticket für meine vorlesung auf dem
schwarzmarkt kaufen ist das ein beispiel
mit dem ich eine diskussion über das
thema haustiere über das wir eben
gesprochen haben
die moralischen fehler als sprungbrett
und bessere beispiele zu finden
ich möchte auch noch mal ein beispiel
bringen anfänglich besprochen haben
nämlich diese idee dass der markt sich
so ausbreitet und dieses diese
marktlogik unsere ganzen lebensbereiche
zu überziehen beginnt ein beispiel dass
sie bringen ist ein kindergarten israel
da sagen sie hätte es das phänomen
gegeben dass gibt es übrigens auch in
zürich dass immer mehr eltern ihre
kinder zu spät in der kindertagesstätte
in der krippe abholen
die betreuerinnen warten verzweifelt
wurden hier die eltern bleiben und weil
das so nervtötend war haben die begonnen
eine bußgeld zu verhängen also wenn man
zu spät kam und die kinder abzuholen
musste man eine busse bezahlen
das resultat war sagen sie dass immer
mehr leute zu spät kamen und zwar
sozusagen absichtlich und sie haben die
busse in eine gebühr umgemünzt
also die eltern indem sie sich sagte na
ja wenn ich alle bezahlen kann komme ich
einfach gleich vorneweg zu spät
was ist denn daran
nochmal genau verkehrt bevor wir
beurteilen ob ihr verhalten richtig oder
falsch ist geht es mir noch um etwas
anderes was zeigt dieses beispiel wenn
ein finanzieller anreiz eingeführt wird
kann sich dadurch die bedeutung einer
aktivität verändern
vorher fühlten sich die eltern die zu
spät kamen schuldig sie fühlten sich
verpflichtet ihre kinder rechtzeitig
abzuholen um den betreuerinnen keine
unannehmlichkeiten zu bereiten finance
getötet durch die einführung der buße
hätte man erwarten können dass mehr
eltern ihre kinder rechtzeitig abholen
würden nach der geläufigen
wirtschaftliche überlegung wenn man den
preis für etwas erhöht sinkt die
nachfrage
doch die eltern reagierten anders was
zeigt uns dass durch den finanziellen
anreiz können sich der charakter der
aktivität und die bedeutung des sozialen
angebots verändern
denn anstatt sich schuldig zu fühlen
fanden die eltern sie würden einfach für
die länger betreuung ihrer kinder
bezahlen und immer mehr eltern kamen
spät
im fall der kindertagesstätte mag es gut
oder schlecht sein einen
betreuungsdienst am ende des tages
anzubieten
ob es schlecht ist hängt vom charakter
der tagesstätte ab wenn sie nur ein
dienstleistungsbetrieb ist zahlen die
eltern einfach für den zusätzlichen
service
aber das beispiel ist wichtig denn es
illustriert etwas das oft vergessen geht
viele ökonomen nehmen an wenn man etwas
kommerzialisieren veränderer man dadurch
die charakter des betroffenen gutes oder
der aktivität nicht
sie meinen die märkte seien inaktiv und
würden sich nicht auf die güter oder
dienstleistungen aus werden
das mag auf materielle güter zu treffen
unabhängig davon ob sie mir einen
flachbildfernseher verkaufen oder ihn
mir schenken er wird genau gleich gut
funktionieren
es ist und bleibt dasselbe gut aber das
ist womöglich anders bei sozialen
80 deren moralische bedeutung von
gewissen haltungen und normen abhängt
zum beispiel im bereich der familie oder
wenn man versucht einen freund zu kaufen
um ein extremes beispiel zu nennen oder
in der bildung im gesundheitswesen und
im öffentlichen leben wenn man in diesen
bereichen marktmechanismen oder geld
anreize einführt kann man nicht
marktorientierte aktivitäten verdrängen
die geschützt werden soll
ein gutes beispiel dafür ist die
hoch-zeit rede die sie auch bringen
anstelle dass der brautvater sich jetzt
da irgendetwas aus den fingern saugt und
eine rede schreibt bled dass ich eine
runde aus dem internet oder lässt eine
auf bestellung schreiben da sagen sie
das verändert das gut aber man könnte
auch sagen der brautvater haben eine
ruhige nacht weil er reißt die rede ist
gut die ich habe die braut und der
bräutigam sind glücklich weil die rede
ist nicht peinlich sondern tatsächlich
gut und alle sind eigentlich besser
gestellt ist es jetzt wirklich so
wichtig dass man die rede selber
schreibt wenn sie präsident oder
premierminister sind ist es vielleicht
nicht so wichtig dass sie die rede
selber schreiben alle wissen dass
präsidenten und premierminister
redenschreiber haben diese bezahlen
nehmen wir aber an der vater der braut
halte eine herzerwärmende persönliche
hochzeits ansprache die alle
hochzeitsgäste zu tränen rührt wintern
die leute später erfahren dass der vater
diese rede online für 149 dollar gekauft
hat so viel kosten sie auf einigen
webseiten wie würden sie sich fühlen
wenn das ihr vater wäre würde das die
bedeutung der rede nicht verändern
es hängt davon ab wie gut der das
natürliche talent des vaters ist weil
wenn die rede zu peinlich wird dann ist
man vielleicht controversy im internet
unter net aber er gewinnt noch ein
anderes beispiel dass mich selber
beschäftigt hat denn die uns vor wir
gehen
eine geburtstagsparty das ist mir selber
passiert es gibt ein geburtstagskuchen
der sieht aus wie spiderman perfekt
gemacht mit marzipan überzogen wie
spiderman und die mutter erzählt mir
sie hätte gerne den kuchen selber
gebacken aber das kind war nicht
zufrieden damit weil er sah nicht aus
wie spiderman
das heißt zum konditor gegangen und hat
sich ein spiderman kuchen machen lassen
wer macht hier genau den fehler ist es
die mutter die den kuchen nicht selber
backt oder ist es der junge der den
kuchen genau so wollte wie spiderman
das ist vielleicht nicht die wichtigste
moralische frage vielleicht hätte die
mutter den knaben überzeugen sollen die
haltung mit der sie diesen kuchen
gemacht hat anzuerkennen oder vielleicht
war es wirklich weise je nach alter des
kindes einfach zu sagen gut ich kaufe
dir einen ich denke der korrupte aspekt
im kauf dieses kuchens des outsourcing
des backens hatte in diesem fall wohl
keine negativen folgen
aber wir können uns ein leicht anderes
szenario vorstellen
angenommen das backen des kuchens war
ein projekt der mutter und ihre anderen
kinder zusammen wollten sie einen kuchen
kreieren der den bruder gefallen würde
und dann sagte junge mir gefällt der
spiderman nicht bitte kauf etwas
professionelleres man kann sich
szenarien vorstellen in denen so etwas
sich negativ auf die familienbeziehungen
auswirken könnte ich denke also es hängt
wie in allen diesen fällen davon ab
welche haltung werte und normen dadurch
verdrängt werden und wie wichtig sie
sind im vergleich zu einem
professionelleren spiderman auf dem
kuchen
womit wir zum größeren bild zurückkehren
wir können nicht entscheiden ob märkte
schädlich sind ohne über die bedeutung
des betroffenen gutes nachzudenken und
zu diskutieren
wir müssen uns fragen welche haltung und
welche normen sind in dieser sozialen
tätigkeit wichtig
und wie stark werden sie durch einen
marktmechanismus verdrängt das zeigt
wiederum dass wir es nicht vermeiden
können über den charakter eines gutes
oder den wert einer sozialen tätigkeit
nach
die menschen fast schon natürlicherweise
sich dagegen entscheiden den markt
sprechen zu lassen
sie selber erwähnen das beispiel der
nidwaldner gemeinde wolfenschiessen
das ist eine gemeinde die schon seit
ungefähr 25 jahre darüber streitet ein
endlager für radioaktiven müll zu werden
und in dieser gemeinde gab es eine
umfrage ich glaube 1993 rund um den
ökonomen bruno es frei und diese umfrage
hat gezeigt dass ungefähr 50 prozent der
bevölkerung bereit war diesen
radioaktiven müll als endlager
aufzunehmen
aus ideen des gemeinwohls und dann hat
man gefragt wenn sie eine entschädigung
bekämen zum start
wie würde das ihre zustimmung verändern
und die ökonomen sehr erstaunt
festgestellt die zustimmungsrate sank um
die hälfte auf 25 warum ist das so und
zeigt das nicht gerade dass wir zu sein
sagen nein danke wir wollen uns nicht
auf die marktmechanismen einlassen
ich finde diese studie von professor
frei und seinen kollegen ist äußerst
wichtig zeigt etwas das viele empirische
wirtschaftsstudien aus jüngster zeit
belegen und das in der moralischen
einschätzung der märkte wesentlich ist
nämlich die einführung von finanziellen
anreizen kann die bedeutung einer
sozialen praxis ändern
genau das passierte im fall des atomaren
endlagers 51 prozent der betroffenen
wären bereit gewesen das endlager ohne
entschädigung zu akzeptieren
und als man ihnen eine ausgleichszahlung
anbot halbierte sich die
zustimmungsquote auf 25 prozent
das zeigt folgendes anfangs sahen ist
die leute als ihre bürgerpflicht eine
öffentliche verantwortung wahrzunehmen
einen beitrag zum gemeinwohl zu leisten
deshalb waren 51 prozent der einwohner
bereit die
risiken des endlagers zu tragen als
ihnen dann aber geld angeboten wurde
sagten viele zum forscherteam
wir wollen nicht bestochen werden sie
empfangen die entschädigung als
bestechung für das gemeinwohl wären sie
jedoch bereit gewesen das risiko auf
sich zu nehmen und diese verantwortung
zu tragen
sie fanden das land braucht energie es
muss den atomaren abfall irgendwo lagern
wenn das hier das sichere ort ist nehmen
wir dieses risiko auf uns aber sie waren
nicht bereit ihre sicherheit und
diejenige ihrer familien zu verkaufen
das empfanden sie als bestechung diese
studie über das atomare endlager zeigt
also einmal mehr wenn man finanzielle
anreize einführt verändert man den
charakter und die bedeutung des sozialen
gutes oder der sozialen praxis die
bedeutung dieser frage für die
philosophie und die thematik die wir
diskutiert haben sehe ich wie folgt um
entscheiden zu können wann marktanreize
zuweilen soziale praktiken und werte
ausfüllen müssen wir nicht nur die
effizienz in betracht ziehen sondern
auch die möglichen korrumpieren den
auswirkungen auf die bürgerlichen
tugenden oder auf moralische güter und
haltung
das zeigt meiner ansicht nach dass die
wirtschaft nicht eine unabhängige wert
neutrale wissenschaft ist obwohl viele
ökonomen davon aus zu entscheiden wo
märkte als werkzeuge sinn machen ist
nicht nur eine frage der
wirtschaftlichen effizienz es ist auch
eine moral philosophische frage und eine
frage der politischen philosophie
das erfordert meiner meinung nach nicht
nur einen öffentlichen dialog der die
moral stärker gewichtet sondern auch
eine neue erfindung der wirtschaft wir
müssen die wirtschaft wieder mit der
moralphilosophie und der politischen
philosophie verbinden
wie in den anfängen der ökonomie zu
zeiten von adams müssen
damals hieß das fach moralische und
politische ökonomie wirtschaft war ein
teilgebiet der moralphilosophie und der
politischen philosophie im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert hat sich die ökonomie zu
einer autonomen angeblich wert neutralen
wissenschaft entwickelt ich denke das
ist ein fehler und muss überdacht werden
aus gründen die diese wirtschaftlichen
experimente zeigen wir können nicht
entscheiden wo die märkte sinnvoll sieht
ohne moralische und staatsbürgerliche
überlegungen anzustellen
wir sind leider schon am ende unseres
gesprächs angelangt aber lasst ziemlich
eine letzte kurze frage stellen micro
sandl
was würden sie selber nie verkaufen
ich denke das wichtigste das man nicht
für geld kaufen kann sind liebe familie
und freundschaft vielen dank
dieses gespräch dürfen sie durchaus
weiterempfehlen
sie finden es wie alle unsere gespräche
immer auch online oder sie bestellen es
als dvd bei schweizer radio und
fernsehen redaktion sternstunden 80 52
zürich e mails schicken sie an stern
kopien srf punkt ch nächste woche
sprechen wir mit ruth dreifuss eine frau
die auch im alter nicht kürzer treten
will insbesondere nicht wenn es um
politisches engagement geht jetzt aber
ist es zeit für kunst kunst die nicht
ganz alltäglich ist
was passiert wenn sich gehörlose
jugendliche auf die kunst der slam
poetry einlassen
ein film über die macht der
gebärdensprache und die kraft der poesie
slam poetry das ist wenn sie wörter und
sätze aneinander reihen und diese sätze
einem publikum vortragen dass spontan
darauf reagiert je nachdem begeistert
oder aber gnadenlos slam poetry
manchmal sind die sätze aufwendig
konstruiert manchmal aber auch aus dem
stegreif gedichtet und damit dem rat
nicht unähnlich slam poetry ist
inzwischen weltweit beliebt besonders in
den usa wo sie auch zum leben erweckt
wurde
nicht zuletzt vom slam-poeten avant la
lettre wie etwa den beatnik dichters
allen ginsberg slam poetry das ist der
offensiv gebrauch von mündlicher sprache
stimmt allerdings nicht ganz
slam poetry ist seit einigen jahren auch
ausdrucksmittel für taubstumme wie das
geht erfahren sie in unserem heutigen
wunderbaren film über menschen die sich
mitten unter uns und doch in einer
gänzlich anderen welt bewegen